Hey, this is really funny.
Donald Trump essentially.
Almost accidentally conceded on Friday, this
is just amazing, you know, Trump continues
to claim victory, he continues to claim fraud.
Even this morning, he tweeted that he won,
but he has been essentially in hiding other
than laying a wreath on Veterans Day until
Friday, the White House announces a big press
conference to talk about not conceding no,
to talk about coronavirus vaccines.
And the expectations were Trump would not
take questions.
He didn't take questions, but yet he still
made this event hilarious and pathetic.
Remember, Trump keeps tweeting every single
day.
I one Biden lost.
It was fraud or fraud, as he says, it was
fake and all of this stuff.
But during his press conference on Friday,
Trump almost accidentally admits he did lose.
He brings up Lockdown's and he says he doesn't
want Lockdown's.
He wouldn't do Lockdown's.
And then as he realizes he's sort of about
to refer to the Biden administration, he finds
a way out of it just by the skin of his teeth.
Take a look.
And hundreds of thousands of jobs every single
day.
Ideally, we won't go to a lockdown.
I will not go.
This administration will not be going to a
lockdown.
Hopefully the the whatever happens in the
future, who knows which administration will
be.
I guess time will tell.
But I can tell you, this administration will
not go to a lockdown.
There won't be necessity.
Lockdowns cost lives.
And they cost a lot of problems that he's
about to say.
Hopefully the Biden administration, which,
of course, is incoming, but then he realizes,
wait a second, I'm scamming my followers,
that I won.
I can't say that.
So he says whatever happens in the future
and this entire event felt like an event put
together for Trump's ego.
And I'm reminded, as some of, you know, Donald
Trump's late father, Fred Trump, had dementia,
quite, quite serious dementia towards the
end of his life.
And at a certain point, they sort of concocted
like a fake work environment for Fred Trump,
where he would still go into work and he'd
have papers on his desk and he would have
a phone and he would think he was working.
But when he would pick up the phone, it would
only the only person he could get was his
secretary out in the main room.
And this almost feels like a version of that
for Trump, where Fizer had already said, listen,
we weren't part of Operation Warp Speed and
Trump's on his way out.
Trump lost, but they sort of like set up a
show, press conference for Trump to feel like
he's doing stuff.
Here is a military general, for example, sucking
up to Trump.
Mr. President, thank you for allowing me to
continue service of our great nation as the
co leader with Dr. Monsef Slaoui on this mission,
Trump does say we won't be delivering the
vaccine to New York.
And this is another instance of Trump wanting
to, I guess, attack Gov. Andrew Cuomo.
Take a listen.
As soon as April, the vaccine will be available
to the entire general population, with the
exception of places like New York State, where
for political reasons, the governor decided
to say, and I don't think it's good politically.
I think it's very bad from a health standpoint.
But he wants to take his time when the vaccine.
He doesn't trust where the vaccines coming
from.
These are coming from the greatest companies
anywhere in the world, greatest labs in the
world.
Now, that's a total lie.
What New York Governor Andrew Cuomo said is
he has a problem with Trump's demands for
a lot of information about everybody who's
vaccinated, which Andrew Cuomo fears could
be used by ICE and immigration authorities
to come and start finding undocumented immigrants
in New York.
And Andrew Cuomo doesn't want vaccination
to be used for those purposes.
It is not about what Donald Trump makes it
out to be.
It's not vaccine skepticism or anything of
the like.
Trump's just lying.
And here is the other clip I really want you
to take a look at.
Take a listen to this.
Pfizer said it wasn't part of warp speed,
but that turned out to be a unfortunate misrepresentation.
They are part.
That's why we gave them the one point ninety
five million billion dollars.
And it was an unfortunate mistake that they
made when they said that.
Yeah.
So this is this is so so let me see if I can
explain how this goes.
Trump did Operation Warp Speed, where he did
fund research for some vaccines and the Pfizer
vaccine is not one of them.
OK, what Trump is arguing here is that because
Pfizer agreed to sell a bunch of vaccines
to the government, if indeed they get an approved
vaccine, Trump says they did participate in
operation warp speed.
The problem is Trump's trying to argue the
vaccine from.
IsAre is almost done thanks to money from
the Trump administration.
That's not true.
In other words, if you come to me and you
say, hey, David, if you develop a really great
electric car, I will buy a bunch of them.
But I'm not giving you any money right now.
And there's nothing I'm giving you that's
going to help you develop the car.
But if you develop the car, I want a deal
that you will sell me 100 of these vehicles.
That's essentially what happened here.
And Donald Trump is trying to distort it,
as always, to try to take credit.
And then Trump, in the end, did wrap up without
taking any questions.
And you're going to hear his Trump kind of
slinks away.
You're going to hear questions being yelled
like, why do you think you won the election?
And many others, everybody, thank you very
much.
So it's really unclear how much more we're
going to be seeing Donald Trump during this
presidency, it could go a number of ways.
We could see him see him all the way up to
the inauguration, continuing to claim that
he won.
We could see Trump leave the White House for
Thanksgiving next week and never come back.
Christmas in December and go to Florida and
never go back to D.C.
It really could go any number of ways.
I'm wondering where you see it going.
Let me know.